taylor swift splits from tom hiddleston  adding him to her long list of ex-lovers  and I'll write your name according to  multiple reports Taylor called it quits  from Tom after just three short months  and what a whirlwind romance this has  been from Swift meet the parent moments  in Nashville and England to Taylor's  annual fourth of July beach bash in  Rhode Island and countless romantic  dates across the globe it seemed like a  fairy tale for these two star-crossed  lovers that is until Tom took off to  Australia solo to film the new Thor  movie while Taylor hung back in New York  City they were last seen together in  July Keller didn't want to come heading  just here on my own buddy ah at least  they'll always have that night at the  Met